wenn du was sagen möchtest dann kannst
du darfst einfach in chats schreiben
jeder zusammen hoch richtig komme ich in
meiner lieben freunde und willkommen
zurück zu captain kreft zwei paar ich
zähle mit erich glaubt 14 dahin ist es
glatt und habe in der letzten folge der
kombi ist auch dabei den handel noch
mandela sommer nicht zu wort kommen so
wie er mich auch nichts wert zu wort
kommen lässt
wir haben in der letzten folge diamanten
gefunden habt ihr ja auch zugeworfen
ehrt die mir zugelaufen das hat nicht
geklappt dann hab ich die ihm zugeworfen
das hat dann geklappt da haben wir zwei
neue archiv - erlangt und wir haben
diese riesige schlucht hier auch
gefunden und wir haben den ball zu
machen
der comedy mich nicht dabei der ist
gerade verhindert da kann man nicht
reden
wir gehen jetzt erst mal zusammen hoch
wenn du das sagen euch dann kannst du
darfst einfach ein chat schreiben jeder
zusammen hoch richtig komme das korrekt
schreib mal nicht schreibt mein chef du
darfst nicht reden und kommen hat in
form und ich wäre halt war jetzt gelernt
man ja ich erlaube die videos wo mein
gott ich habe dazu bisher
ich wurde von dem der oben weggesprengt
und will einfach vor den geladenen im
halben herzen
er war das wird sie nicht mehr mit der
luft explodiert war da schon wieder
sonst glätte hallo pizza
wie kommen denn jetzt nach oben das gar
keine natürlich hier entlang kollege
immerhin drei jahre aber da fehlen ja so
ein paar dinge immer nicht sonntag ich
habe schon mehr als einmal außerdem
erhielten hier in der ding das ist
gleich viel kann ehrlich nicht 8 hat
sich wieder zusammengewachsen auch das
stimmt ihm wachsen nachdem gegensatz
weiter sport bei korrekter feld wo alle
hier siehst du mal abgebaut
ach quatsch weil ich einmal ausleuchten
ich brachte wieder fest alter was hier
los
ja weil du deine faktoren gesetzt das
habe ich mich auch unten gemacht das war
von mir also wir haben jetzt nämlich die
ich hab mir lohn kern und du hast
kakaobohnen richtig ich habe carolina
habe ich gar nicht nein die sind doch
hinter der wand
hüsten die sind doch hinter der wand
nächsten damals haben wir auch bald
denn wir müssen nur auf serien abbauen
und das nächste schiff müssen jemanden
seiten aus der anderen seite auch weißt
du denn dass die kakaobohnen hinter der
wand sind weil man sie doch da sieht die
sind nicht hinter der wand da kann man
schon an der jetzt wieder mal hin
lissabon der stadt rechtlich wegen banks
in dem was dem links gegen den wegen der
braunen farbe weiß bloß nicht sterben
konnte öfter das ist wichtig ich hab
eine kakaobohne die anders in die lava
gefallen glaube ich nein der eine reicht
ja erst mal mein alter ich hole bei
diamanten und er ist vor allem junge
liegt nicht sterben konkrete aussage
nicht herrn graf ist
wo kamen daher gerade ewig und wieder
immer aus dem nirgendwo im alter alte
alter komme um mein gott oh mein gott
eineinhalb herzen
oh ja ich jetzt digger geil ich beeile
dich bei dich ja was soll ich machen
schnell runter ich generiere gerade erst
wieder nämlich wenn jetzt kommt ihr war
einfach mal ein kritiker die meinen
ganzen sachen was hatte ich an
wertvollen sachen essen gestorben wo
bist du denn gestorben
die diamanten tod alter komme kaum
schnell wo bist du gestorben sag mir wo
du gestorben bist ja öfter hauptbrücke
schnell die erwarten wo sind ich habe
noch gesehen wie sie direkt geflogen
sind
auf der hauptbrücke ja ganz oben bei
denen die jahren auf der höhe
ich bin schon wieder da weißt du
bekommst das nicht hin aber nicht ich
bin ja selber hier gerade so ein
bisschen da kommt karten vom bbi zu dir
hoch geschwommen nein ich habe ja kein
alter jetzt wieder ans klettern
das kann es nicht sein jetzt geht wieder
alles schief aprils haus beleuchtet und
die blöden sportler die sind auf so hart
eingestellt wenn wir bei dir
okay ich habe hier unten braunmühl von
dir liegt hier um hier liegen noch ein
paar sachen hier liegt emerald die dias
hinweg alter hier liegen sachen von dir
die liegen ganz nah neben der lava nicht
dass die dias wie lava gefallen sind als
hier oben keine diers komme hier sind
auch keine da nicht doch noch eine wie
kannst du denn auch sterben mit denen
die als ich weiß es nicht
hier liegt nichts liegt nichts man
einvernehmen
hier liegt nichts ahnt warum schickst du
mich helmut kraft finde ich alles gut
das war aus der höhle rosen naja wer
wäre wäre ich auch deutlich für pkw sind
bei dem fast noch ich hab schon gedacht
wir haben nur einen tropen roth woran
halt dieses dings hin
diese kakaobohne der restliche baum der
ist ja mal stück hat einfach das wasser
rasch wieder aufgefallen der baum muss
hier am arsch das neue werk einsetzen
rausbekommen diesen proben baum ja das
ist ja auch so eine scheiße dass wir
einfach kein setzlinge aus bekommen
haben
es ist so voll das kann nicht wahr sein
jetzt muss eine schere mitgebracht weil
ja mach du das mal wieder voraus gedacht
hier
du denkst immer voraus auf jeden fall
ich habe einen tropen mode er ja toll
mitgemacht setze ich einfach keinen
keine filiale hin
na gut egal ja ich komme schon mama mama
gespräch heute gar nicht mehr
kakaobohnen alter der name bakterium bei
der so nah an mir dran bist wundervoll
dahinter schon das wasser hatte ich grad
anzeigen
diamanten ich hatte so angst davor aus
das war ja so krass habe ich gedacht das
ist ihm diesmal nicht falls wir die
diamanten verpackt da dachte ich mir
schon sofort wir wollten alles richtig
machen und jetzt haben wir das mit dem
baum verpackt und das gejammer nicht
aufgenommen hätte ich aufgenommen ich
hatte einfach die ganzen folgen
überdehnt roll durchgezogen glaube ich
ich glaube ich jetzt einfach ich hab mir
auch gedacht wenn ich die diamanten
finde dann werde ich dir auch behalten
und sagen ich werde dich treuen wir
haben keine
das hat er habe ich mir auch gedacht
aber dann hab ich mir dann ich habe
wirklich keine bekomme der hd man man
man
olive brauchen kakaobohnen tageslicht
oder doch ehrlich ja klar die wachsen
brauchen den proben na gut brauchen
nicht unbedingt tageslicht ich setze sie
trotz immer noch oder egal ich setze
einfach irgendwohin lieber die truhe
hier aus der unterwelt ja erstmal
pflanzlich hier kurz die rats wieder
noch ein skelett am rand ich bin auch so
glücklich ich habe das tropenholz noch
die neuen stücke ist das gut dann kam
mir noch ein bisschen mehr um sie links
anzupflanzen sagt lege ich mal der
hammer wir kommen auch immer mehr in
diesen raum da sind noch blog auf gold
guck mal hier steht blog auf emerald das
heißt beim nächsten archiv nennt wir
haben das toll viele levels er wir
müssen aber noch viel mehr abbauen dafür
gewannen sie mir doch noch gold und so
abbauen na ja echt gold ja da steht der
blog auf gold her stimmt krass also wir
haben noch elf gold gold gold gold
mitnehmen bombardieren spitze kommt ja
ich mache mir noch ein paar gold teile
ich war schon wieder zehn gold ich
glaube ich kann sogar schon blog auf
gold machen
ja es kann schon blog auf gold machen
nicht alle drei oder ja nur ein
schade na gut aus so weit sind wir noch
gar nicht soll ich wieder runter und
einfach mal oxidieren abbauen für den
erfolg und amerell und amerells 11 mark
block haben wir schon also emerald blog
wir wollen wir neue eine neue die die
kiste dahinter setzt auch die seltenheit
ist ok ok ich pack' die melone kerner
rein so des wasserstandes kies gut
lautet ein strohballen für pferde oder
wofür braucht man strohballen für pferde
für nahrung doch auch glaube ich für ein
hase
weiß ich nicht da vorne ist ein zombie
der kommt nicht durch unsere tür muss
uns gar nicht stören
hier kommt noch dazu fräsen reihe hatte
da kann ich gleich aber neue die ganzen
suppen scheinen
ich habe neun sollte welche geben hat
eleganz auffüllen guck mal hier endlich
hat ja auch nicht mehr dieses blaue
nervige hier an der seite und wir können
ja die ganzen sommer braun schau mal
dann können wir denn in den stall oben
erweitern
dieses fass mainz mit blaues nervige die
boarder die welt grenze das blaue meer
vergiften
was suche ich dachte schon hell was ist
denn für dich blau nervig so wartet das
kommt noch der welt da sind gleich ist
schon klasse schon knochen dran
wir haben eine angel haben wir hier viel
holz ja krass hier oben du musst ja gut
so fiel auch nicht mehr aber immerhin
einige stücke
montafon ich hier wieder nur soll damals
noch in ruhe von unten einen blog
aufgeholt haben wir schon und auch ein
emerald blog ja ich bewege mich kann es
mir noch etwas zu fressen geben
er erwarte ich komm hoch ich konnte in
den lava einmal packe ich auch mal kurz
daran macht das sonst wo er starb denn
hier unten wartete ja ich komme ja okay
da da da da da muss reichen
jojo die krippe sie sprengten sich in
die luft
wo kommt der denn her alter weiß das
blöd bei diesem projekt sind die spore
normalerweise dass born aber durch die
sportler die man mir noch mal zu euch so
ich gucke ob ich das zuckerrohr und die
kiste finde ich jetzt gestorben mit der
stier spitzer grund und und und und du
gehst obsidian abbauen erstmal ja genau
obwohl brauchste eigentlich gar nicht
weil die folge ist gleich vorbei
dann kann ich das in deiner folge gleich
machen also ich bin jetzt hier und bei
den gängen und die katzen sie motzen
wiederwahl herrliche warte hier war das
dann müsste das glaube ich nie was ich
hier durch ich packe ich hätte
vielleicht die schere mit dem soldat
hätte ich noch mehr von diesen mitnehmen
können gut dann machen wir es mit den
obsidian echtem einer folgen
naja ich ja alles mal ein wenig schöner
aus weil die hier ja ich hab's ja und
ganz viel goldnuggets ganz fein sattel
ein atelier für schweine ja ich werde
beim nächsten moment irgendwie hatte
kann man den pilz kuhweiden geht das
nehmt es geht das spiel ja nun ja man
man man muss sogar das mitschneiden
machen stand da irgendwie habe falle mit
einem schwein so und so unter das heißt
wir müssen auch ein schwein warten
ich laufe trotzdem hat man noch durch
die gänge und suche europas auf wegen
krüper mache ich hier ist onyx ich hatte
vielleicht die schere mitnehmen sollen
die sind so viele lian hier ist nix nix
ich möchte dieses zucker aber auch noch
finden
dann können wir endlich den kuchen
machen ja oder zumindest erstmal an
pflanzen oder das genau
wir hatten da ja irgendeine stelle oh ja
stimmt wird die wiederfinden
ja in einer die suche ich nämlich gerade
und unten ist ja alles gefunden aber
nicht ein kettenhemd ganz viele pfeile
und slime bolz okay ich brauche mal nach
irgendwie blog auf slime oder so ich
kann heute sagen ja das können wirklich
gut sein kann hier jeder von uns hat
jetzt nimmt also ich kann dir meins
angeben
ich hab auch ich alle in hof 1 ja ich
suche die ganze zeit nach dem zuckerrohr
was soll das überdies denn los mit mir
zuckerrohr los mit dem und diese blöden
wolken jena ist der kater gefunden
schon wieder eine ja aber dafür bauen
wir noch ein paar ski fans habe ich bau
dir mal ein bisschen frei
ja da wo du gerade bist es ist so
verdammt unübersichtlich wenn man da mal
irgendwie eine halbe stunde drin ist hat
man auch danach wenig so wenig
kopfschmerzen
ja ich bin wieder bei dem spot gar
keinen sinn wieso bin ich wieder bei dem
spot gar nicht mehr durch
wo war das denn wo geht's denn hier
runter ich kacke dann sein
hier sind noch gänge
hier war ich glaube ich noch nicht doch
dabei die höhe oder waren sei nicht auf
der höhe oder war es komplett woanders
nenne ich gehe noch eine etage tiefer
so ist wenn ich hier in etage tiefer bei
ich hab's ja buch endlich ruh
ich hab das zuckerrohr gibt das
zuckerrohr und ich habe im sattel
jetzt komme ich nach oben und ich hoffe
ich finde den weg hatte war nicht
irgendwo die kannst du vielleicht mal
die leiter runter klettert kommen dass
ich die ich sehe
irgendwie kann man doch nicht ich finde
doch nicht er ist auch gern leiter sind
da sind ja nur die ranken
weil ich sie den namen schon kannst man
wahrscheinlich auch sehen wir nur nach
oben kommst du guckst ich laufe den weg
ich hab noch holz gefunden warum die
menschen auf seiner höhe hoch hier ja
ich hab noch eben holz und kohle
gefunden moment wo waren hier der
eingang für eine hülle krass ich würde
aber sagen wir machen das alles in der
nächsten folge ich komme auch in der
nächsten folge nach oben da musst du
mich jetzt hier nicht so blöd noch
ausloten welche ihr land noch voll für
ich bin wahrscheinlich da wieder roboter
bei dir gewesen oder
ja bist du gerade weil ihr auftritt bei
vitadisplays ag ich mache das alles in
der nächsten folge dann werden wir auch
zu kommen zurückkehren und das ein oder
andere eventuell knacken oder das ein
oder andere monument und dann hallo ist
da abholen tabellen dem jetzt auch noch
eben töten werden
hier ist ganz viel holz miteinander gut
ferner werde ja ich baue das eben ab wir
sehen das alles in der nächsten folge
wieder lauten haken bei komme und
spülmittel